hi there this is steve uh and this is
the second in my
series steve's summer sessions where i
hope to be able to answer questions uh
put to me by those of you who follow my
youtube channel
and of course as you'll remember i ask
you to submit these questions via
twitter
ask steve
so last week i spoke about reading
comprehension
and getting to output
and today there are two questions that
i'm going to try to handle one is
do i recommend studying two languages at
the same time
and the second one is what do i think of
space repetition systems or srs systems
and including sentence mining
two languages i'm often asked this
question
i think the most important factor there
is
what you yourself like to do because i
know there are people who are quite
successful at studying two three four
languages at the same time i've seen the
video of professor argez
where he has
i don't know how many languages on the
go at the same time and they are all
accomplished language learners
personally
i find it very difficult
because i find that starting a language
from scratch is a major commitment it's
an emotional commitment a commitment in
time in focus in energy
and i find it very difficult to direct
that kind of focus energy emotion to two
or three languages at the same time i
prefer to focus on one for a period of
time six months twelve months then focus
on another
uh if i have a language let's take my
present situation i have spent the last
six seven weeks
focused on romanian
prior to that i was focused on korean
so having dropped my korean i will slide
a bit but when i come back from romania
and i focus on korean again i won't have
lost very much but if i had tried to to
do two of them i don't think i would
have made any significant progress
in romanian
uh i believe it's possible to
have a very heavy heavy emphasis on one
language the one that you're starting
with and to spend 15-20 percent of your
time in a sort of maintenance activity
trying to not slip too far behind in one
or two other languages and i have been
doing this i occasionally read something
in czech occasionally read something in
in russian out of interest
but those are languages that i'm further
ahead in i don't think that i could have
80 of my time on romanian and 20 of my
time on korean because in both those
languages i'm not sufficiently
along in the language that i could treat
it as a minor activity both of those
languages require a lot of focus so in
my own case if it's a matter of learning
a language from scratch i would like to
go at least eighty percent if not a
hundred percent full time full bore full
focus on learning that language once i
achieve a certain level in the language
then it's possible to diversify so if i
wanted to if i leave a romanian and
korean out of it where i'm still at the
sort of beginner advanced beginner stage
um russian and czech i could do russian
czech and portuguese at the same time
because these are maintenance activities
because at that time
my learning activity is more a matter of
enjoying the language i'm already at the
stage now where i simply want to enjoy
an interesting podcast in czech or
portuguese or russian
because of the subject matter because it
brings me up to date on events in brazil
or portugal or russia or the czech
republic so it's just an enjoyment thing
and if i run into people where i can use
the language i speak the language so
those are not the sort of
hard core heavy lifting that you have to
do when you start in the language if you
are at that hardcore heavy lifting
rather
you know
you know forgetting a lot continuing to
make the same mistakes
not feeling confident in the language
there i motivated to get better i'm
motivated motivated to move up to that
next
shelf that next level and therefore i
tend to commit myself full time so there
you have it that's my take on it if
you're at the early stages in the
language i would recommend based on my
experience
that you do one at a time all right
second question was space represent
space repetition systems known as srs
there's um
i can't remember there's an key
there's uh gosh
memorize there are a number of them out
there we have
in link we have a spaced repetition
system as part of the package of
functions that
we provide
there are many people who swear by anki
it's probably the most popular to judge
by what i hear
uh you even have the gold list which was
put forward by
david jones i believe his name was
where you write certain things out and
there's a certain repetition
um
period and it's all based on the idea
that
that uh if you review certain some
things within a certain period of time
you won't have a chance to completely
forget it that there is and there are
even algorithms which apparently are
scientifically derived
and and therefore ensure that you will
revisit a word or a phrase uh within
that sort of
period of time that's specified by the
algorithm
okay personally i spend very little time
with those kinds of systems and that's
not to say that they don't work for some
people
or maybe for many people i don't know
but if you are asking me what i think of
them i find them uninteresting
you know
i don't have my statistics handy but i
would suspect that in romanian in the
last seven months
i have
looked up and therefore linked on our
system
gosh i don't know 20 000 items
uh like lots like i'll go in and read an
item and i'll go through and if there's
200 new words 150 of them bing bing bing
bing bing i'm linking them in our system
and then i go away and read it on ipad
and if i go i can go through five of
those in a day so now i'm at 500 600 in
one day
i don't think an srs system uh would
keep up with me so pretty soon i'd have
an imagine unmanageable
uh list
deck i think as they call them
uh to try to go through
so
that
that's one problem the other problem is
i find it rather boring to go through
uh these words i do the flashcards at
link if i am waiting for five minutes uh
somewhere where i have a short period of
time
because the reading or listening you
have to get into it so so if it's only a
very short period of time i might flip
through these flashcards
i'm not sure how much good it does i'm
sure it does some i enjoy doing it if
it's a short period of time but i
couldn't do it for half an hour and i
couldn't do it for half an hour
a day every day
whereas i enjoy my reading and listening
and i believe
that
the whole idea with these spaced
repetition systems is that you're going
to review the most important words more
often and so forth well the most
important words because i read massively
and listen to most of what i read
i'm getting exposure to the most
frequent most common the high frequency
words
and again because i read that link or on
my ipad i see the words that i have
saved highlighted in yellow so i'm being
reminded of them so i believe that i
have perhaps not a scientific or not an
srs
system based on
some algorithm but i'm getting
sufficient exposure
uh
without forgetting
so that in fact
by my massive reading and listening i do
accumulate these words and phrases
so but that is how i like to spend my
time uh where i do review words and
phrases i tend to do it before or after
and both
uh studying a particular lesson
because it gives me a little bit of
extra sort of um
you know attention to those words and
phrases so i focus on them a bit more
when i listen and read so i am not a big
user of srs that doesn't mean that it's
not good for you where i'm where i used
srs a form of srs a lot was when i was
learning chinese characters where i
developed a system of my own where i
would make sure that in writing these
characters out i would revisit them and
rewrite them within a relatively short
period of time because it is true that
if you leave it too long you're more
likely to to forget and it'll be harder
to learn sentence mining i didn't really
know what it was but i looked it up
and apparently it's a system proposed or
recommended by katsumoto
now for those of you who don't know
katsumoto is gosh i don't even know
where he's from
but he's an english-speaking person who
lives in japan
and who is extremely fluent in japanese
and who has developed a variety of of
language learning tools and aids and one
of his uh favorite methods is sentence
mining and
i think all it means is that you save
sentences or phrases and
transfer them copy paste or type or
write them out long hand whatever onto a
list so that you're extracting
key sentences out of the text that you
are
listening to or reading and then you are
reviewing them in some manner what do i
think of sentence mining well
i guess i have a few thoughts on it i
have never done it in terms of saving
whole sentences i think the key
sort of element is the phrase the phrase
and the word it's not just the phrase
you need individual words you need to
learn these individual individual words
because they will appear in many
different situations and the phrases
if they're key phrases they'll appear
quite frequently but the sentences are
far more unique so
personally i'm not that interested in
learning uh you know specific sentences
because there's so many vocabulary items
to learn so many words to learn so many
phrases to learn
that personally i have never
been that attracted to the idea of
trying to nail down
whole sentences however i definitely do
mine
to use that word the text that i listen
to and read that's the whole process of
again link creating links of whole
phrases or
words
then that i see highlighted in yellow
subsequently when i read
again the answer on the sentence mining
is a bit like the answer
with regard to srs that i prefer to do
that kind of learning vocabulary
accumulation as a natural
byproduct
of the listening and reading that i'm
doing aided by the
you know
highlighting of these words and phrases
that i have saved and for me i find that
effective but i that doesn't mean that
there aren't other people who would
benefit from both uh srs and
uh sentence mining so again i've talked
a bit longer than i wanted please keep
sending your questions in
and as i say
once a week every week i will try to
answer at least two of them so thank you
for your attention bye for now
you